if you want to have success in
multi-level marketing you have to
educate your team and show them how they
can use their stories to help them bring
in sales hi I'm Evan Carmichael I
believe that hunger entrepreneurs
deserve help today maintain a question
from a YouTube viewer Brian who wrote in
on a video that i wrote video that i
made the video talked about how most
multi-level marketing businesses suck
because the entrepreneur is behind it
the people who are trying to promote it
they don't have a passionate story they
don't believe in what they're selling
they're just giving some stock website
and they say you know drive people to
your website which sucks and nobody buys
of course because the web page sucks
there's no personalized content and so
nobody's going to buy then the person
gets a scourge and they leave your
downline that's not how to build a
successful multi level marketing
downline so Brian wrote in it's my
little rant great point I think the best
MLM distributors come from people who
are already using the products and
loving them yes I love we said about not
just taking the website that the company
gives you but instead making a
personalized telling your own story
could you address this a bit more what
are the necessities of MLM is the need
to duplicate simplicity deep into your
downline this builds a team how does one
be innovative while still keeping within
the system so it's all duplicatable a
great question Brian and if you figure
that out you're on your path to huge
success the way I would do it is it all
starts with bringing on the right people
okay you could spend tons of time
recruiting and their the wrong people
and then you're spending your time
training them encouraging them
motivating them on videos on calls on
emails with them trying to support them
and they drop and they're discouraged
and it gets you discouraged first don't
focus on the quantity you've got to get
the quality people make sure they use
whatever your product is if they are not
willing to use it and love it then you
don't want them if they can't talk about
your product in a way that is
personalized then you do not want them
it's got to be someone who's actually
bought the product that's your first
test will they buy the product and will
they use it what do they think about it
before you sign them up to sell it see
if they like it
somebody would sign up without buying it
without using it I don't want them
because they're not going to be a good
salesperson for you you have to believe
in it so that's that's step one you do
that you're going to save yourself tons
of time and I don't care if you don't
have a hundred thousand people in your
downline you're going to get quality
people and they're going to make sales
you're going to get results that's what
it's all about okay after that so we're
working on getting the right people in
our downline next you have to show them
how they can use their story okay
usually whatever MLM network your part
of they give you a website the websites
always suck but at least it gives you a
platform to start with you don't need
the fanciest website you need the
fanciest technology but you need to have
the passionate story so what you need to
do is show your downline and their
downline as it keeps going down how they
can tell their story in a way that
empowers people to want to buy the
product and join the company it doesn't
have to start with anything fancy it
could just be a bio to start with so
bare bones basics have a picture of you
smiling looking professional have your
picture on your website tell your story
even if it's a couple paragraphs written
tell your story give them examples of
successful stories ones that work ones
that have been you know maybe written by
a copywriter right have been approved
give them a structure tell them what the
call it tell them what to put in each
paragraph not what to write exactly but
give them an overview in your first
paragraph you're going to say how you
discovered the company in your second
paragraph you're going to talk about why
you bought the first product in the
third paragraph you're going to talk
about how it's helped you so much in the
fourth paragraph you're talking about
why you joined the business and see it
as a revenue opportunity those are
examples explain that teach them how to
do it and give them samples from other
people from your own example the best
way to do it is you have an awesome
example yourself and you can show people
how to tie into it you don't want people
copy and pasting it but you're educating
them it's duplicatable but they have to
do work you still have to do work if you
want to have success as an entrepreneur
MLM or any other business you still have
to do some work if the guys aren't
willing to write a bio put their picture
up you do not have the right down line
fire them don't waste your time on them
if they can't put in that much work
you're working with the wrong people
you've got to get people who are willing
to work you want hustlers so that's a
start and that's not that hard you get
the right people that's not that hard to
do they can be taught and maybe you even
higher copywriter just to review it make
sure there's no mistakes give them
suggestions how to make it more powerful
you could have them do videos it doesn't
have to be a fancy video if they have a
laptop with a camera and they speak into
it and say why they started why they
joined this business what they love
about the products and it comes from the
heart it'll be way more impactful than a
professionally done crappy video that is
you know the usual stuff that you see it
has to hit people so don't worry so much
of production quality okay make sure no
they're not in their kitchen that's
super messy behind make sure they're
wearing something respectable than on
their undershirt there's some basics you
can write okay some basics shave make
your hair look nice okay but tell a
passionate story and it may take a lot
it takes I knew for me when I first
started doing videos they sucked it took
a lot of practice one of the camera to
get better to get comfortable and so you
can guide people and walk through them
have them give you samples upload it as
a private video to youtube but you can
give them feedback or people in your
network can give feedback and what to do
better again if somebody's not willing
to do a video a simple video where you
sit down in front of your laptop and
talk how are they going to be out there
selling for you bringing in new members
selling product how is that going to
happen you need the guys who will do
this and you can lay that out up front
and it's better to scare them and say
here's the work you have to do to make
this successful if you do the work
here's the results you can expect and
they're fantastic but if you are not
willing to do this stuff thank you very
much you move on to somebody else you're
not wasting your time and I know you
want to bring in as much people as
possible but if you bring in the wrong
people you're just going to chew your
tires you're going to waste your time
you're going to have a huge downline
with no income coming in but I don't
want that for you
so hopefully there's a few ideas in
there for you if you want to show me
something want my feedback on it I'd be
happy to do it I'm excited for you it
sounds like you know what you're doing
in your business you believe in your
product and we're on the same wavelength
so I'd love to be able help you a little
bit more for those of you watching you
like the video you agree please give it
a thumbs up below and I want to hear
from you what do you think about this
video you agree with me disagree please
leave in the comments below I really
love seeing those come in they make my
morning every day and if you have a
question for your business I'd be happy
to answer it again leave it in the
comment section below thank you guys
have a great day and I'll see you soon